[Music]
all right episode five we're gonna go
ahead and fix up even more cups the cool
stuff with the classes and macros and
then uh we're gonna get into making a
little combat system so here we go all
right so first things first i've already
done it because i just kind of was
testing something out and this works
beautifully
just below where we have pc construct
and level up we're going to make another
define of character class and this is
essentially the definition of the define
all we need to know about is class name
base hp base strength and base int
and then we can define this whole class
here so you can see it basically looks
like all the classes look so far
except
there's the class name so that'll pass
forward there and base hp will pass
forward there and it's going to cast to
the correct type
and same with strength same with int and
here with the get class name we got to
use the string eyes operator there and
that turns it into a string
and uh
here we go here's a web page about these
directives if you want to read more
but yeah we're basically just keeping it
very basic using the string eyes once
there's other stuff you can do if you
want to get fancy with it i'll leave a
link to that down below
and then uh we can delete all these old
classes all we've got to do to make a
new class is this so here's our cleric
here's our wizard here's our warrior
here's our rogue all this class stuff we
had down below
uh yeah we're just going to delete a
whole bunch of lines of code just like
so
and like so
and now all we've got is we just went
straight to the player character down
here this really reduces the code or 110
lines for all this and if we want to add
another class we can do so very easily
and just like so
zerker
and we're going to buff up these classes
a little bit i think because it's going
to make it a lot more fun berserker and
start with six strength one intellect
let's make the warrior five strength two
intellect so i think we're gonna have
uh seven points there i i feel like if
you have
more hit points
then maybe
yeah we're buffing up the hit points a
little bit you have more hit points than
maybe you should have slightly lower on
some of the other stats
so just playing around with that a
little bit of rogue we're gonna make
them pretty pretty even down the road
uh i feel like rogues have more
intellect than strength i really need
like a dexterity
in here and heck we could just do that
real quick we could add dexterity if we
wanted to
but i think we're gonna save that uh for
another time because i really want to
get to this battle system and get some
attacks and a little combat thing going
on
all right so cleric 14 hp
uh let's go the stick was to strength
for an elect
since they got looks like lower hp maybe
we give them a little more stats
maybe we'll go
uh three and four
and we'll make the rogue like like that
something like that oh and let's go
three and five
and the rogue can just stay four and
four nice nice down
down the middle of the road there
warrior
so yeah i feel like if you've got lower
hit points you're gonna get eight
opening stats
that can make our wizard go all the way
up to
well we could even go like this with the
wizard no strength at all just full-on
on the
on the intellect but
yeah that that's pretty good and they
even have lower
uh hit points than anyone so maybe we
even give them just give them another
little boost there so they even got nine
points to play around with and then
there we go berserkers looking a little
weak now with this new meta system but
pretty high strength there so there we
go nice little classes nice little class
system
berserker barbarian whatever you want to
call it i'm going to keep this i like
berserker
and there we go we'll leave berserker in
there
and now
with those changes in there of just that
other macro
that really really simplifies things a
lot makes it so easy to pop new classes
in here
and uh expand this later
so uh there's one thing i still want to
do and that's prevent
these instantiating these by themselves
but i don't see any clear easy way to do
that i was searching around online i
couldn't quite find any answers so we're
just going to have to
make sure we use this player character
all the time when we're using a player
character and who knows maybe maybe we
do want to instantiate these for other
reasons later we'll find out so let's
get on to a battle system shall we
battle system let's talk about this for
a second and uh let's let's talk about
where we're going with this because you
might have noticed that a lot of this is
being designed on the fly in the code
which is not what you're supposed to
ever do
like
do you ever take any courses on software
design
you'll know that one of the steps to
making software
is
the whole design phase where you don't
touch any code
we sort of did that and you know the
first episode we hypothesized some
things but we didn't have anything set
in stone so basically
we don't actually have a real design
we're just winging it
and then typing out code
which and it's it's just something i do
because
that's my my way of getting into it
sometimes but
that's not the way you should actually
do it you should fully design it first
and then you should bring out the code
and make it a reality with your code and
the design
can all happen on paper or with charts
and stuff like that in little flow
charts you want to do all that first so
since we haven't done that
we really need to otherwise we're going
to get really messy
that's
that's what's going to happen here
all right so berserker is just just uh
we're going to delete it it's obviously
op in the stats anyway right now
we're going to stick to our
core four
and we need to think about
how we're going to design
the battles the game what the game loops
going to be like what what stats do we
actually need
uh for the battle how's the defense
gonna work what's the chance of hitting
is there damage reduction you know we
have all these things
to decide we're gonna do that right now
and as quickly as possible so i'm going
to go ahead and pull up the readme
um
code readme on the console here
and bring it up in visual studio code
and we have this whole thing put it uh
that's not what i intended to do
let's just work on this for just a few
minutes here i don't want to spend a
whole lot of time here but we we got to
do this
really this is better done on paper in
my opinion but
this will be fine
all right we've got some stats
right now
we have
hit points strength and intellect that's
that's the only three things we have
i feel like we need to have dexterity in
there or some kind of dodge
that or reflex
and
we could combine that with strength we
could say
yeah we could combine it with strength
because that sort of works
oh geez all right let me let me take a
few minutes offline here and i'll come
back with
a design then i'll explain the design
time warp
we're there we're on the next day all
right i spent some time thinking about
this a little bit and uh i know i said
we do the combat system but i don't
think we're quite
ready yet because
i don't think our characters have enough
stuff to really be fighting and also we
got to decide what we're fighting so
what we're actually going to do today is
we're going to add armor resistance and
agility just a few more stats and
another thing the thing we were kind of
working on sure this is a really cool
example of a macro but i i think this is
going to cause a problem when once we
get to leveling trees so i've added a
few new things into the readme just
about uh
what these stats do
and uh the level tree section so
i don't think we're gonna get to level
trees today today we're all we're really
gonna do is we're going to
add in more stats in preparation for
battle and
then i think the level trees are are
going to be going to be nice and good i
also did some just adjusting on what
these character classes do and what
they're
supposed to be doing
so yeah as i was saying you should
definitely be designing all this stuff
before you get to coding that makes a
ton of sense and uh
i'm just not going to do that
oh god why
so
let's add some more stuff now we don't
necessarily need to get rid of this
macro right away we can just add in some
more base stuff and update this level up
and how it works
and that should be okay but we need to
think about armor there's another thing
that came to mind that we're not really
putting in the game
that we probably should and that is
different races we're kind of just
assuming everyone's a human
right now but once we start introducing
monsters that kind of also makes people
start asking the question can i play
some of these monsters what about the uh
other races that aren't necessarily
monsters that are more
good aligned say can i play as those and
that sort of thing and
for right now that's
let's not worry about that let's just
assume all the characters are humans all
the player characters or maybe they're
not maybe they're something else but
we're just gonna
kind of use some power of imagination to
to not worry about it
that's a weird way to use your
imagination isn't it
all right so let's add in some of this
stuff we're going to have a base
strength base and now let's also add
base edgy
base agility
base
edgy
so now we have to specify that when we
create a class and we'll say our cleric
has four
our wizard has
well four is too much for player let's
say
let's say one wizard one
warrior one
and maybe warrior two
and rogue
five and we can lower
uh some other stuff on the wizard let's
like let's drop the intellect down to
three
on that
and maybe we'll drop the strength down
to three as well just balance it out a
little bit
so we'll go with something like that we
might also
lower this lower this
okay
we don't really know how these balance
tweaks are going to work until we
actually start doing combat and putting
that kind of stuff in there but now this
should populate forward that agility so
that should work but
there's a few other things we need to
update as well like this level up how
how's it going to level up the agility
we could just add it in here
the same way
just like so
obtain and turn this one into agility
and
turn
let's see here
we need to add it to this player
construct
and on this level see if there's
anything we need to do here doesn't seem
like it i think we're okay here
but our stat block
we should probably put agility in here
as well
so we will just do that
some quick copy pasting stat type
a
and we can level them all at once it no
longer knows what agility is so we'll
just populate that all in here
just the same way we were doing the
other ones
and we need the actual stat of course
and just make sure we set
the full constructor
now another thing we could do here just
to save a little space
is well we're typing this over and over
we don't actually need to do that we can
say strength if they're all the same
strength equals agility equals you know
they all equal each other and they
ultimately equal this something you can
do with c plus plus if you're signing
variables all the same thing is you just
line them up like this and put whatever
they're equal to at the end
saves us a couple lines of code a cool
little trick i like to do
but of course you can't do that with
this since they're all different
assignments
but often it's a quick way to construct
and reset variables too if they're all
resetting to zero you could just do
something like that or reset into a one
in this case
and there we go that adds agility to our
stat block and i think we want to add a
few more other things to our staff lock
armor and resistance so we're going to
go ahead and put those in here too now
these are sort of different
armor
resistance
i'm counting armor is like physical
resistance and just plain old resistance
as element resistance
now
there's some design decisions here so
uh maybe we should even call it element
resistance to make it very clear
because some things might be more
resistant to
hot and cold and stuff
and there's probably going to be
different types of magic there might be
magic that just does force or physical
damage and there might be magic that
does element damage so some might magic
might be resisted by armor some might be
resisted by element and we can also
specify the different kinds of elements
but we're not going to worry about that
that'll just make it too complicated
we're just going to call this element
res actually
just to
shorten it up a little bit
and we can default those as well and we
can just start them all as zero so we'll
do that in the default constructor here
armor
equals element res equals stat type zero
so we'll just start those as zero
and here we go with the instantiation
of the explicit version of it and i
don't think we necessarily want to well
we'll put them in here but we're going
to do it in this special way
we're going to go
armor or well stat type here
call it arm in this case so it's
obviously different than agility but
we're going to put equals
zero that way if you don't specify
it'll just set it to zero
just another cool trick you could do
i don't know if it likes that it
probably doesn't
i don't know if you can do casts right
here either it might not so we'll play
around here with that i get a bit here
and we'll also put stat type
elrez that works here and we'll just set
that one to zero as well if they don't
say
and yeah we'll catch these we'll be sure
to cast them
i don't think i've ever casted in
default constructor values like this
before or whatever these are called
exactly i forget
but it's something let me just do
element res equals zero or
el res
so
now what this does
and i don't know if explicit is going to
mess this up i don't think it will
because we can still use it the way we
used to
but
uh what we can do
you know
let's actually get rid of this default
constructor
i don't think we're gonna end up using
it so let's use this explicit one and
let's just put in defaults because we
know we want this to default to
one
you know
we'll add these stat types back in here
shortly but just to shorten it up
and show you
this will essentially be a default
constructor if you don't specify any of
these because it'll default to these
values just a cool trick you can do in
your headers
so now while we have this explicit
constructor we also do sort of have a
default constructor too or default
default values that they're going to set
to if you don't specify now when you do
them in this order you also have to
specify in this order so if you only
want to set one thing you still have to
specify the ones before it
a sort of weird thing but this is going
to make it a little more modular and
we've got our new stats in there for
that stat block
and we've got increased stats here again
we should probably go ahead
and put these other ones in here as well
stat type arm stat type
type state type out of half
so just correct that real quick
and add these in here
and there we go our increased stats is
modified up so we could also put in the
default values in these as well
which is kind of cool
that means we can use it as necessary
and since these are all plus equals
zeros it's going to be a great default
value it just means we don't want to
change it but this allows us
to
i'm not sure what i can't remember off
top of my head what this is called
but
it basically just allows us to use this
in sort of a more
modular way
when you do this sort of thing but uh
yeah i think we're going to be pretty
good here let's also put a get armor
that just returns
armor
and a get
element res
that just returns
element
rest and now the way this is built here
it shouldn't mess up anything we've
currently built so let's just
try and build this and see if we get any
errors
we get a few
says get intellect is already oh this is
supposed to be renamed to get
agility
and let's try to build that again
and we have some
uh
redefinitions it says oh that's because
we need to rename this one
there we go
and we don't need base armor and base
resistances because those are all just
going to be zero for the classes and i
think maybe once we once and if we add
races maybe some races will have some
some base armor and stuff but for the
character classes i don't think it makes
sense to put that in here
so another problem with this class that
i was talking about a moment ago
is that
we don't have ways to like add level
trees to certain classes uh we can we
can cobble together a way but we also
don't have ways to say this class you
has mp this class says energy or
anything like that with these different
uh well types or point wells
so that's something to think about in
the future but for now
we've got the stats in here we've got
agility in here we've got armor and
magic resist prepared that are probably
going to be affected mainly by items or
special abilities or special spells and
stuff like that but they're sort of
future proofed and in there and how we
got everything succeeding there
and now we could specify this or make
this class a little fancier
by just adding some more things in here
like uh let's go ahead and put the
agility in here
and we'll also add
we could put armor and
resistances
of course these are going to be zero for
now and i spell get agility wrong
i must have let's we'll figure that out
a second
and this one will be
we'll just call resist it element
so this is just a sample
sheet
okay and we need to figure out why
doesn't it like those right now let's
hit play and just see what it does it
says it's not a member it's because we
need to define it
down here and the one we actually
instantiate
we don't have the functions forwarded as
we should so it's just going to be
basically the same as this get agility
or you know the same as the ones above
that returns the pc class its ability to
get agility now this can allow us to do
some other cool stuff and this player
character class is going to become more
useful once we have armor because for
example in this
get armor
we'll be able to do stuff like
uh yeah we're of course going to get the
armor
but we also might have something like
plus pc
class
get
race armor or something like that too so
what uh
we'll be able to combine
results of things and do some special
stuff in this board it functions based
on all the things that are cobbling
together
these classes
so
that's this player character is going to
become more and more useful as we go
forward and we might even end up stating
than something here like
like
maybe an inventory
star inventory and we'll define the
inventory delegate
somewhere and have different types of
inventory because maybe there might be
like an equipment set stuff you can wear
type inventory and there might be you
know we gotta decide that later but the
point is we'll be able to add this
add to this as we go as needed and so
that's gonna make it
pretty handy for expanding
get element res
there we go forward that
because it all looks pretty
standard right now like we're basically
just copying the same names but the
point is that we don't have to and
we can do special stuff with these other
than just forward the functions because
we could say like get current well
you probably get the point there let's
move on i'm gonna go ahead and hit play
here make sure this compiles
there we go we're working with a warrior
currently zero armor and resist
that's fine looks like everything else
is working pretty good there
now has some bass agility that's going
up with them
so let's check on
let's check on the road here
and that looks pretty good rogue getting
the most agility there
and
rogue
rogue looking pretty thick i don't know
i feel like i may have over buffed the
rogan warrior but it's hard to tell
because we don't have magic involved yet
because like the stats of the
the wizard is obviously lower but
we haven't accounted for
how powerful
magic is going to be and how effective
it is but these low hit points it seems
like
well really high intellect there's a
really low strength and agility but
really high intellect i guess it's kind
of what we want we want strength for
each class that way it makes sense to
play certain ones based on your play
style and we also have to decide in the
future are we going to do party battles
like are you going to be able to put
some people together
we're definitely going to be going into
a battle scene i don't think we're going
to do open world battle stuff uh or
anything like that we're definitely
gonna be
we'll probably
in the future be walking around in some
kind of world or level and when you get
to certain instances it's gonna proc a
battle scene kind of like the final
fantasy games and chrono trigger and
stuff like that and uh maybe even like a
super mario rpg where when you run into
an enemy you don't like fight the enemy
on the map scene you go into a special
battle where you do start doing your
stuff and take turns
i like that idea so
that's going to be
the follow-up from here but i think
we're going to keep it's really simple
here and just leave this episode a nice
update of the stat block and go from
here i'll see you next time don't forget
to like and subscribe and consider
supporting this channel further if you
want to get a little bit more
bonus content patreon
uh join button
and uh discord if you're having
more trouble or just want to hang out
with other coders but
yeah we do a lot of the advanced
troubleshooting there if people are
getting stuck on code or not you know
stuff like that
anyway
there's more i could say but i don't
want to ramble on let's end the episode
thanks for watching
[Music]
you